hey you guys time for another movie
retrospective this time going back to
the very early 80s going back to a film
that I have actually been wanting to do
for a really long time and the shitty
thing is that I finally decided okay
we're gonna do it and I remembered that
it was on shudder so I said okay I'm
gonna watch it again tonight and then I
went on shudder and it was gone yeah 45
mins 45 minutes luckily to be TV had it
so if you want to watch it you can
actually watch it in there for free it's
just a couple commercials in there and
stuff like that not to be mistaken for
45 great actually very good it's 45 kind
of like I Spit on Your Grave time it is
sort of um yeah it's also called angel
of vengeance came out in 1981 directed
by Abel Ferrara who before this he had
made the driller killer in which he
played kind of an artist that loses his
[ __ ] and starts to killing people with a
drill just as the title way they have
sometimes yeah you know before that I
believe he had done porn I think he did
one nine lives of a wet [ __ ] and [ __ ]
which yeah um so I've never seen the
porno but I have seen driller killer
which I actually I really like it's
actually more of a psychological it
sounds like a slasher but it's really
not this is like kind of sleazy er but
miss 45 while still quite sleazy is
actually it's actually a lot more like
accomplished and it's been restored I
think Alamo Drafthouse films just got
the rights to it and they rereleased
like a really nice restored version I
think in 2014 I haven't seen this one in
a long time Jason
recently I didn't see I've seen it a
whole bunch of times and I was like
bummed out like I said when shudder took
it off like the very day I was gonna
watch it and then I was like well I
could probably do it from memory because
I've seen it so many times but then I
noticed that TV about it so yes so I so
I have watched it like very very weird I
think I was out riding a
during that time you probably know
you're actually asleep I watched it
let's do like earlier yeah while I was
like working on some other [ __ ] I
haven't seen it forever I remember it
but it didn't really stand out to me at
the time so I'm not really the one to do
the review on it yeah well you can like
pop it I'll pop in on it yeah this is
yeah um I think in the in the 70s and
80s mostly in the 70s there was kind of
um a little mini genre of what they call
rape revenge
movies yeah miss 45 is probably one of
the best-known examples probably the
best-known example is I Spit on Your
Grave which was actually remade in 2000
why would you want to remake that that
original was what it was that did yeah
remake and honestly um I might do a
review and I spent in your grave because
I I know that that movie gets [ __ ] on a
lot um not as bad people say it is but I
actually really like it's just it's just
it's the content of the movie that's so
much that it has the most horrifying ape
scenes in it like the most horrifying
like realistic rape scenes in it I mean
for a long time I watched it I could
yeah it was like I had a hard time
watching it yeah and I've seen like a
lot of like really bad like horror
movies and stuff but it was just there
was something just so gross and like
real about licky we're watching it
really happened like a snuff film oh
yeah it was kinda like watching that
first Texas Chainsaw Massacre that that
kind of comes across as Rio in a weird
way but it's not yeah it's like just has
that gritty like oh man I need a
Silkwood shower now well and I feel like
you know Abel Ferrara's films Abel
Ferrara's films you know he's in New
York filmmaker and he was making movies
a lot in the 70s and 80s in New York
when it was still like really dirty and
filthy and dangerous and that really
really comes through in a lot of his
movies probably more so in driller
killer but in this one as well um I
would call this one a rape revenge
although it differs for my spin on your
grave in a lot of ways I mean I Spit on
Your Grave is basically you know this
poor woman goes to a cabin to work on
her novel for stupid rednecks gang rape
her and then she just [ __ ] awesome
yeah like cuts out their dicks and why
not
yeah um you know so she is you know she
is very directly taking revenge on the
people that did that to her
now miss 45 is a little bit different it
is actually the story of there's this
girl and her name is vana and she is
actually played by Zoe Tamara's Lund who
I think she was only 17 when this movie
was made she was a beautiful beautiful
girl model screenwriter she actually
covered the screenplay for Bad
Lieutenant which was one of a before
hours later movies and she was also a
musician she actually died of
complications from a heroin overdose she
was one of those people that she was on
heroin and she loved heroin she would
like tell everybody she thought heroin
was like the greatest thing ever
so Billy Idol's surprisingly yeah yeah
so she actually did end up dying from
that I think she was only 35 years old
but she is actually great in this so she
plays a character called Santa who's
mute she's not deaf but she can't speak
she works in the garment district in New
York City she's like a seamstress or
something yeah now uh on one particular
day she is walking home from work she
got walks to a grocery store she's
leaving the grocery store and a masked
dude pulls her into an alley and rapes
her fun fact that first rapist with the
max on the mask on I'm pretty sure
that's able for he's doing some weird
like Dario Argento I always use my hand
to stab [ __ ] in my movies you think
so because like I said Abel Ferrara was
also the murderer in troller killer so
it's just I don't know I guess so so she
yes so she gets raped in an alley which
you know that's horrifying enough then
she's all you know [ __ ] up and
everything and then she goes back to her
apartment and a burglar has broken into
her apartment and he also rapes her so
this is not her day is what I'm saying
now this second [ __ ] that it's
in her apartment she actually ends up
getting the better of him and ends up
smashing his head in
an iron justifiably so and so he's like
dead in her apartment now because of
this horrible trauma she basically
slowly it's not actually not that slow
because it's a pretty fast-paced movie
she pretty much loses her [ __ ] and
decides she is just going to go on a man
killing spree around two New York City
innocent even the innocent what's well
um that that's like I said that's why
this isn't really like a classic rape
revenge because what she doesn't get
revenge on the first guy that raped her
cuz that ended a mask on now the second
guy she does kill him and he's in her
bathtub for a day or two and then she
decides well I guess I better like cut
him up right so she starts cutting up
cut it and she cuts him up like wraps
the pieces in newspaper and put some in
garbage bags and then she's just gonna
go around New York and like leaves them
and you know alleys and garbage cans and
stuff like that yeah now as I said it's
it's kind of like a fine line because
you really you're rooting for her
because this poor [ __ ] girl and it's
like you know what I mean she had some
problems before she's obviously very shy
and very you know she doesn't talk or
anything but you know she has some
friends at work but she's not really a
joiner or anything so this horrible [ __ ]
happens to her and there's this whole
this the kind of theme the whole
overlying thing of the movie is that
what you know when her and her friends
or her co-workers like walking down the
street like there's just these like men
sting there's like leering at them and
just like making horrible like sexual
comments and like trying to come on to
them and stuff which is actually pretty
accurate
um you know what I mean depending on
where you live and I think in New York
at that time too it's probably probably
even worse and you know even [ __ ] I
dunno
having around here when I used to walk
around my work and stuff like that so so
it's almost like these women are just
kind of like in this stew of like just
male hostility like coming at them from
all sides so you can almost like
understand why she would do that because
initially the dudes she bumps off they
didn't do anything to her directly
usually but on the other hand you don't
feel too bad about hey you know what I
mean just because they seemed so [ __ ]
douchey like the like the one guy that
she kills like she's like I said she's
cutting up the body of the of the rapist
and she's kind of slowly like depositing
pieces like all over the city so she's
doing that one time she has a you know
it's his arm or some [ __ ] like that I
don't know where it is and like leaves
it in a bag and like kind of drops the
bag and then this guy who has been like
catcalling like every woman walking by
like he sees her put the bag down and he
thinks that she dropped it
so he picks it up and starts running
after her which uh you know I would be a
little frightened by somebody running
after baby like so she like [ __ ]
starts running and so and then she gets
trapped in an alley and then he's like
yelling at her and like waving the bag
at her stuff and she just shoots him in
the [ __ ] head you know what I don't
think I've seen this movie you don't
think you feel I don't think I've seen
this movie yeah yeah hear you hear you
tell I want to see it no it's actually
really good but uh yeah so like it
sounds like just woman goes crazy kills
random men yeah well it does go in that
direction but she doesn't like the thing
is it's like you could you sympathize
with her up to a point but then she like
crosses a line where it's not okay okay
you know what I mean yeah it's not
saying that that's it's not thanking
it's not saying it's okay yeah okay
it was kind of like um you can tell it's
very much influenced by death wish taxi
driver you know movies like that just
kind of those gritty 70s like revenge
vigilante type movies because at first
like I said she just comes across as a
vigilante because she you know she
shoots a pimp that's like beating up a
prostitute like she sees it and so she
shoots him yeah um you know so she
targets like dudes at first that are
just better shitty and you don't really
but then as it goes on she gets crazier
and crazier and she just starts like
following just random dudes and be
like yeah I'm gonna kill that dude I'm
gonna kill that dude and all this other
kind of taxi driver was a masterpiece
though it really was although like I
said I really like this one too
it's just um and it the cool thing about
it one she's amazing in it she doesn't
say anything she only says one word and
I'll you know say that at the end but
cuz that's kind of like the big end
scene but so everything has to like be
conveyed by her face and she has like
this really really great like I mean
like I said she was a model and
everything uh you know among other
things so she has this really she has
these really big eyes and she's like she
has this really beautiful like
expressive face and she's really good at
like showing trauma
you can almost like tell what she's
thinking like by looking at her face and
it's I'm surprised that she wasn't in
like a lot more movies but she was kind
of like I said she was more into
screenwriting and she was a musician and
stuff yeah but um but like I said she
just it so so it goes on like I said she
kind of gets more and more people as and
the sad thing is like even people even
men in the movie that are that care
about her or that are ostensibly nice to
her are still kind of shitty because
like she has this boss at her that her
you know the garment district where she
works and he seems nice but the way he
talks to her like she's [ __ ] or like
she's like a little girl or like a
little kid or something he's like just
like really condescending yeah and he's
also kind of creepy and rape me it's
like he's a one of those hey let me give
you a massage type of like that type of
dude you know what I mean so that's what
I mean about you know when she goes
around killing people you don't feel all
that about it because a lot of these
dudes are like really are no prizes yeah
but like I said she does kind of cross a
line at then you know she kills gang
members and stuff like that that are
like threatening her but as day goes on
you know as time goes on she starts
using what she starts doing you know at
the beginning of the movie she starts
out very mousy she has kind of like
mousy little hair and she dresses kind
of mouths and everything like that but
then as she gets like sexier and sexier
like leather pants she starts wearing
like red lipstick and likes licking all
her hair back and good super villain
yeah because she's trying to like lure
men toward her you know what I mean so
she can kill them now the the kind of
climax of the movie like her [ __ ]
boss because she's been because of like
the trauma she went through with the
rape she didn't tell anybody about the
rape she didn't tell anybody would have
happened to her so they all just thought
she suddenly started acting really weird
like she you know she kept [ __ ] up at
work like she burned [ __ ] with an iron
and you know Stefan did buttons wrong
and whatever and so they just think
she's like losing her [ __ ]
and so her creepy condescending boss is
like you know why don't you hang out
with the other girls more you know I'm
having a Halloween party you know you
need to come to that you can be my date
and if you'd be my date at the Halloween
party then I'll like forget about all
this all these fuck-ups you've been
making at work and she says okay so the
Halloween party at the end is like where
the big climactic thing happens now her
costume famously and there's a very
famous image from this movie is like
sexy nun you know what I mean she has
the habit she is this big there's big
red lips because she has like these
really great like really full lips it's
not fake or anything and she like has
the the sexy nun outfit with like you
know the [ __ ] stockings and she's got
the 45 that she so that alone might make
the movie worth seeing yeah
yeah that's what I mean and and like I
said that's it those are very iconic
images if you google the movie that's
most of the images that come up or her
and the nun outfit like on various yeah
like you know she and she's like take
the bullets and like kissing the bullets
and stuff like that the 45 by the way
that she got was actually from her the
guy that had broken into her apartment
that she killed and cut up so she took
that gun and then went around like blown
with New York New York City yeah and
this movies from 1981 if I don't say
that before but yeah so there's a big
Halloween party 70s no no it was it was
clearly influenced by a lot of 70s
horror movies or seventies like revenge
movies and brie pervenche movies and
stuff like that but yeah it came out in
80 81 so the big like Halloween party at
the end you know basically the boss
who comes across is I mean he comes
across as gay but I guess not maybe he's
bisexual I don't know but um he I don't
know he just seems like a like a gay man
but he's all he's all into her and he
likes to start smacking on her and stuff
like that so she shoots him and and then
start and then comes down the stairs and
all the homies and she's targeting all
the men she lets like the the women are
screaming and freaking out too obviously
because she's shooting men but you can
see she's just going around just plug in
all of them and then the best scene of
the whole movie and like I said she's
mute she doesn't say a single word do
the whole thing except for the very end
what happens at the very end while she's
shooting all the men one of her friends
from the company one of her co-workers
who's actually a really good character I
can't remote her name is but she's the
one where they're all walking down the
street like dudes are like like hey baby
then she's just like [ __ ] off [ __ ] off
you know what I mean she's all like that
so she's kind of like this really like
assertive like woman that I was always
telling all these guys to go you know
piss up a rope or whatever so fana is in
there no nun outfit like shooting
everybody
and this assertive smartass woman comes
up behind her picks up a very phallic
looking knife from the cake table and
like does it like that and then stabs
her in the back with it so she saves
everybody except for the people that
they already got and then fana turns
around to see who has stabbed her like
it's kind of like slow motion and she
sees that it's a woman and the one word
she says his sister hmm and then she
dies but yeah it's no it's so [ __ ]
good but yeah ruined it no no I'm okay
it's an old movie it's an old movie all
right but there's like I said there's
just such there's great little details
in this movie like just little [ __ ] like
when she goes back into and she goes
back to her apartment before she when
she gets raped the second time she
actually gets the upper hand on the
rapist by first hitting him on the head
with like a big ceramic apple like Eve
you know what I mean from the Bible and
then she kills him with an iron which is
a very feminine you know appliance I
guess you know okay so she kills him but
she kills moon iron they also have a
thing where when she goes like before
she goes back to the apartment where she
get her before she gets raped the first
time she's in a grocery store and all
she buys is like the thing of meat and
then like some soda so then but then
like later on when she cuts the guy up
it's like she's cutting it like it's
meat and then like wrapping it like the
same you know I mean so there's like
lots of nice little little symbolic kind
of things in there like that kind of
thing but yeah so this is actually if
you haven't seen it that's you know I
know I just wrote it in everything but
but that's what I do that's what I do
but you definitely should see it like I
said it's technically it's a rape
revenge movie that's usually what its
categorized as I even wrote like a big
blog post about this and I Spit on Your
Grave like kind of talking about the
differences between them because like I
said this one is a little bit more
problematic in that you know and I Spit
on Your Grave you sympathize with her
because she gets raped and she just
directly gets revenge on the dudes that
actually did it whereas this one you
know she starts out like you sympathize
with her but then as it goes on you know
she just starts targeting people that
didn't do anything to her or weren't
doing anything bad so you can't really
get just fun you can't really justify it
so so it's not really the same thing as
say like you know I don't know I guess
it's sort of similar to like death wish
type of thing but you know it she just
it kind of reminds me a little bit more
than you know this is like a vigilante
thing it reminds me a little bit more of
like a psychological study more like
maybe like repulsion or something like
that where you know she's clearly not
right you know I mean like the movies
not saying hey it's okay to go blow
random dudes away even though some of
them did deserve it but you know later
on as it goes on obviously they didn't
deserve it
there's also I forgot to mention -
there's this really good scene where
she's in a bar and she like picks up
this guy and this guy is like telling
her I don't even remember I don't know
what this actors name is he's only in it
for like two or three minutes but he's
so great and he like is given this big
long like spiel about his wife and how
he was afraid that she was cheating on
him and all this other stuff and then
like one day he followed her and then he
looks in the window of where she went
and she was like having sex with another
woman and then he says something like I
so I went home and I strangled her cat
and then so thany points the 45 at him
and is gonna shoot him like after he
says that mmm because she's like you
killed the cat [ __ ] you but it doesn't
go off but then he takes it out of her
hand and she's just kind of like looking
at him like that and then he shoots
himself in the head she's like well I'm
getting the [ __ ] out of here but there's
just like there's just like really
really great scenes like that so if you
like that there's kind of gritty like
New York like when New York was like
really gross and disgusting basically
Detroit yeah back and it was like that
it's it really really has that vibe to
it it kind of reminds me of like I said
the whole taxi driver if God told me to
you know all that kind of like filthy
New York because of you know big alleys
full of garbage and all this other kind
of stuff and everywhere you go like
there's all these people like standing
around street corners like grabbing you
and [ __ ] like that it's all that kind of
thing but yeah it's just so it's it's
one of those ones I I feel like it
doesn't come up a lot but I really like
I always really liked it I like I Spit
on your grape - I like a lot of this
scuzzy like rape revenge type movies but
I would definitely recommend this one if
you haven't seen it it's on to be at the
moment so you might want to go see you
watch it for free yeah you can watch for
free is just a couple commercials in
there I don't think it's like caught up
or nothing like that but yeah like I
said April Ferrara went on to do other
you know Bad Lieutenant probably most
famously but he's made a [ __ ] ton of it
he's still making movies nowadays I
thought which I didn't even know until I
looked at this what
Rinka pedia page and I honestly didn't
know that Zoe Tamara was lund who was in
this actually co-wrote lieutenant as
well so that was that was a fun fact
that I learned when I was doing this
move here alright so we are gonna wrap
up this short review of ms 45 go check
it out if you like that type of thing
and remember if you like our show like
share subscribe on all your social media
if you'd like to financially support the
show you can go to our patreon page
patreon.com/lenguin
every Sunday and our regular episodes
that come out every Tuesday so check
them out we will see you next time bye